welcome welcome welcome welcome h 3r me
this is your leader foolish Maximus I am
joined here by mother motherfu Bish's
it's a play on teresa but with Fupa the
return of mama kleine
we are the mom army mom Army's I love
them all Marmee how was it mom the one
and only is back she's here she's
looking beautiful and healthy and
wonderful how does it feel not only to
be the head of the mom army but to be
here in your bunker in your battle
station once again and it feels great
and I feel like I'm forgetting a million
stuff like we it's the first time we had
to come here with the baby right and it
just feels like can we show that Dan we
can yeah mom she was just feeding him
and now he needs to burp yeah that burp
is very crucial yeah he feels that pain
but he like he struggles with that bird
man
mm-hmm and it's all it's just he's like
it's all you burp you poop and he works
on those poops to look that's like a
full fish I'm just like oh you could see
his face like no but he's a little
warrior right oh yeah yeah we went to
the doctor and they said he's very tall
yeah there they said that he's strong
how do they tell that and I wait how can
they tell he's strong I guess cuz she
was moving him and he was like resisting
his muscles that little curd has such a
grip like sometimes I'll be holding him
and it'll grab my neck and I'll be like
oh dude what the hell yeah okay he's
strong so they actually they rate your
baby I love that rape my baby calm they
rate your baby on a percentile like a
standardized test so he isn't in that
86th percentile on height but everybody
buckle up because he's 93 percentile on
the head size this kid's got a dome dude
what the heck
that's crazy he's got a huge head but
big beautiful brain let's not start to
bully him because we love all size heads
he's gonna be looking back at this era
but I said well anyway yeah I know I
gotta be careful now yeah he's gonna
watch but I'm saying that you got
lovingly
he look it's a matter of fact he's got a
big head he's a baby
you see that's [ __ ] up I would never
say that to like joke like that with a
conscious son mm-hmm again I don't even
know him
maybe he's down yeah I feel like it'll
be done he's a goofball
he's a champ I don't know if we
mentioned sponsors oh [ __ ] hold on I got
to pay for the adores college well thank
you to Dollar Shave Club audible door -
and stamps.com we love and appreciate
all you guys thank you so much well guys
let's get right into the show we've got
mama Klein back with us now cue the
music because we have a little
announcement here make we have come in
crazy
we have come in out of our minds because
today we are doing a Teddy fresh fifth
in Brazil 50% off special we're talking
Bob Hart shirt I Heart mob all the
colors we're new here tan blue purple TF
heavy cotton from toilet bag the mom
Chanel sweater my heart you sweater so
get all over the Teddy fresh dog card
and sugared Isildur this trip that we
lost our boy ela
thank you for cutting that exactly what
he said time we these are actually all
stuff that we really like but we're
trying to move inventory you know we got
a new stuff so a lot of times you guys
say you know I want this but it's too
expensive so preach
sir now is the time all right now we've
got all that out of the way let's talk
about this video this is a really deep
cut and yeah and I played it last week
but I didn't fully explain it I mean I
didn't talk about it but there's this
guy on YouTube named tubes and this is
such a deep cut it's the guy cut
together every philip defranco frank
franco intro of him saying sup so let me
give you an example here but it becomes
really becomes really hypnotic but it
starts to lose its meaning even the
motion itself I'm gonna count you to
watch all 11 mats of this well sure he
does change his face you could probably
tell a lot about the man's life based on
the speed of the Sun at the time you
know I mean like you could analyze be
like yo your shops around August you
know July or you know October with
spaghetti right slow sluggish stops
where if you go to January February
March very quick and chirpy subs and
never make this one thing I will say
that it has not changed what any of this
is his [ __ ] hair like his hair I don't
know how he does that man but his hair
does not ever change candle yeah wonder
why they changed the background
probably just test it off she gets
misplaced the background that's true
don't subject me dude don't stop check
me bro I don't have a subject when I
open the show my goal by the way with
this is to see how long I can play it
during a conversation it's 11 minutes
every stuff ever performed see when I
open the show I have enough thing I
don't know what's the word that's gonna
come out of my head so you can't subject
me I wish I think there's something very
you know powerful about milling what's
the word where you know where to start
tuning out should I stop this well turn
it down we turn to death I mean it's but
it's pretty so anyways I guess I guess
you get did see that was three minutes
it felt like wow I thought it was at
least six yeah I really thought we were
I'd say it's put up sup army I challenge
you to watch all 11 minutes of that that
is very impressive about his hair his I
don't know how do you consider what well
now he's got a hair products okay
apparently the guy knows what he's doing
but he's got that hair like that really
thin straight hair where you could be
like yeah the guys that I always [ __ ]
hated in high school where I was like
the guy goes like yeah and it's always
like he takes off a hat and he's like he
just came out of the barber yeah I was
like haha you're cool and girls in high
school love that too
well there's I used to be envious of
girls like that too when like just the
straight hair and don't need to do
anything it's just like always perfect
right
[ __ ] those people I bet they're mating
somewhere having kids with perfect hair
yeah well my kids heads [ __ ] huge so
[ __ ] your perfect hair my kids heads in
the 93 percentile [ __ ]
Arcana my hair is like you put gel and
the hair still curls however I want to
jail there's nothing
Theodore's hair is gonna be freaking
he's gonna have like Hermione hair you
know crazy for all you Harry Potter fans
out there hair mine you hear yes so
maybe with the sub bombs tubes I gotta
give a shout out to your boy tubes who
went through the effort by the way as
impressive as feel different ghost hair
is this guy went through every goddamn
episode and cut this up so shout out to
him here let's see he said this took way
too long to edit I actually wonder how
long it did he said how many videos Oh
someone says running that two times
speed everyone's like okay fine are
they're moving on no no I mean I'm
assuming that you guys find this as
interesting as music I want to just
spend the whole episode on I find it to
be very fun and enjoyable but here we go
to time speed wall gets back to you
that's what I was saying to his hand he
has different hand motions it's this can
really study is what is that by the way
like what is that what is this motion
though what the hammer it's almost like
grabbing your hug so what is this handle
cuz you do this like hey that's the one
that goes with your back
taps your back right right okay so
you're a oh yeah daddy was we slapped
him in the face really yeah which shows
reverb I'm sorry everybody this is the
worst episode we have to have
interesting stuff to talk about we have
good stuff to talk about I swear know
everyone take a deep breath
what up sup army so we are the sup army
now they do you know burp I need to know
his Theodore burps what's going on with
the burp updates is he changing he
sounds like I heard he burped and he
pooped in peds your mom's been busy back
there okay so um gee these mother
fricking Hecker's um G we all know them
as universal monkey gobblers Universal
Music Group what is it that's right yeah
you Buena versal monkey ball gobblers
these guys have been running amok on
YouTube for so long claiming every
freakin video imaginable and we're all
so pissed off and fed up with um G so
how do you suppose we all react when
Susan Wojcicki the one and only tweeted
out excited to partner with um G to
remaster some of the most iconic music
videos of all time on YouTube it's like
how about before you partner up with the
enemy of the people you tell them hey
stop stop destroying our platform and
taking the livelihood from all of our
creators and of course everybody rips
into our occluding myself I will so
disconnected because like um G like I've
heard it from so many youtubers by now
and I I barely spend time on Twitter but
it's almost every time I open Twitter
there's something about them I don't
know they're tone-deaf they're just they
don't really think is they don't really
Ingle with youtubers like susan goes on
a PR tour where she meets like the most
insulated kid-friendly youtubers I mean
she met us that was nice and I and I
told her about this absolutely
but she'll go like once a year and visit
like Lysa Koshi and they're like oh man
YouTube's great I make 10 CPM I'm so
rich everything's perfect I never get
claimed you guys are doing such a
fantastic job this is ins like oh thank
you all right I'm on my way to go see
I'm on my way to go see a superwoman
yeah and she's like I'm always on
trending and my seat PM's are so good
and you guys treat me so well and then
Susan's like Oh YouTube is the best
we're doing such a good job
I think she comes and sees me and I'm
like she was very receptive to my
comments but they are tone deaf they're
just not involved so everybody's
blasting her I said I will not be
viewing these until UMG pledges to
improve their flavor and copyright abuse
until they have no grounds to ask
support of YouTube community for which
they harm everyday and I'm saying
hashtag boycott um G I'm not gonna watch
this [ __ ] I didn't ask for this I don't
need to see it in HD of you you're
taking away their charm anyway you know
what I mean you don't need to read what
do you uh George Lucas got a remaster
the classics no can we agree that George
Lucas is a big fat idiot
a big fat idiot I mean no no I take it
back he's a chin lesedi --it he is
undoubtedly a chin listen that is that
is completely but I I I hated George
Lucas from the moment he added that
extra canteen scene and the originals
with this music I I agree with that the
man is a genius but no Zach no no but a
man that created Star Wars I mean come
on yeah he didn't write even the
screenplays as I understand it of the
originals well he didn't he didn't yeah
additional writers well he's a mixed bag
okay you know what I'm I am i and we all
know yeah he did [ __ ] up a lot of those
scenes huh yeah we all agree he's at
least endless yes George Lucas
you gotta see his like his beard his
awesome epic that's some nice hair
no his facial errors [ __ ] fire dude
but he's got no chin I don't know why
I'm giving the guy's [ __ ] what was they
been talking about what were we okay
remake a remaster poor George Lucas he's
sitting here minding his own business
what the [ __ ] did I do
I can only imagine if like George Lucas
is watching this somehow or it's just
like all of a sudden yeah George Lucas
ain't watching this don't kid yourself
idiot talk about chinless fat idiot
speak for yourself I kept going I said
this tweet was claimed by UMG the enemy
of the people destroyer of worlds
undo ur of YouTube mister be supposed to
image they said the illiterate could use
the hundreds of thousands of dollars
they profited off of just my videos
alone and he posted a these are all UMG
claims and some so claiming is one thing
but the examples you see time and time
again are so egregious
that's what really messes you up for
example there's a video where mr. beast
simply hums the tune briefly mm-hmm and
the whole video gets claimed there's one
from Gus here I've got all the examples
since one can you're not how my song I
sever since um G got their hands on on
copyright baby so general that's not a
thing right yeah and some people even
claim just for like saying the name of a
song like yeah I don't love a famous
song but that's not if you humming a
tune well how I mean I don't honestly I
don't know but why would you I don't
know I doubt that
like there was a there was a big legal
case between UMG surprise surprise and
some lady who took a video of her baby
with music playing in the background and
they filed a DMCA to remove the video
like like people are watching this baby
dancing to listen to music in the
background it wasn't even like a
complete song was just a snippet they
took that they took him to Supreme Court
and they said [ __ ] you mg and anyone she
won nice and so so there is some justice
of course there isn't that works like
who's gonna go all the way to Supreme
Court because um gee they've got been
nothing to lose I'm going to boycott all
this because um she's continued blatant
and flagrant abuse of copyright as it is
a detriment to the entire YouTube
ecosystem I'd ask that team you to
cancel this partnership until they make
good-faith efforts to improve their
methods boycott um G yeah they didn't
answer they don't give a [ __ ] about me
Susan's like uh we spent like millions
of dollars on this so you can [ __ ]
yourself I have some great examples here
and let's see here's some youtubers
responding I want to show Gus's video
because this one is kind of epitomizes
this is kind of [ __ ] Johnson friend
of the show there's a lot of youtubers
that were pretending to hear Brahimi and
rap see for the first time so I made
this video about it where I talk about
the issue if the video is called why is
everybody lying about Bohemian Rhapsody
I talk about the issue
I don't play even a [ __ ] microsecond
oh yeah
not at all I remember the video today Oh
this claim was manually clean not even
automatic detection fair [ __ ] you
claimed this video as containing stuff
from EMI Music Publishing manually
[ __ ] clean EMI is UMG right then uh
yeah um she bought EMI about five six
years ago so yeah mm-hmm that's when
they got that's when EMA am
I started claiming everything on YouTube
so I remember his video he was in his
room just ranting like why does he's
just saying kept going like why does
everyone keep pretending like they don't
know yeah that's the video that we
always really like yes but so he doesn't
even play no even for a second no wow
because I didn't remember if he plays he
doesn't it's like a one-take of him so
this is the kind of madness that's going
on here and UMG is definitely getting a
pass because I happen to know from being
close with YouTube that when people make
these kind of flagrantly abusive claims
they can get kicked out of the system
yet UMG owns 30% of all the music in the
world and of course instead of you know
reprimanding them it's hey guys we're
excited announced that um geez big ass
their [ __ ] that's thicker than the
circumference of the globe is in my ass
Susan Wojcicki I'm just saying you know
their logos of globe so it's like a big
ass in handle beard it's not
she's taking up that one dude I don't
like I'm just kidding she's a sweet lady
yeah she's just into anal fetish
probably fits um G I'll be in to a old
fans for um G those [ __ ] are
rich oh you're getting that we were slam
on them with regular Megillah trying to
cricket me or something no I'm actually
curious about all this new song it's
just a lot of Ethan Bradberry we were
looking at the scope of um G they truly
are such a behemoth I mean these
[ __ ] need to be broken up by
the government for having a monopoly
because they own every goddamn one yeah
I mean it's it's over 30 percent of all
the published music nowadays and it's
like if you just look at their list of
big artists it's it's it's everybody
it's all like the superstars they're all
under that it's like in all genres do so
if you want to see what all the hubbub
is about and by the way I'm sure I'm
gonna get claim now for
a New York Times article it's called
this goes out to the guy who's manually
claiming this podcast right now it's
called fair use there's an exception for
journalism
oh yeah it's literally from a New York
Times article guaranteed to be claimed
so if you want know what all the hubbub
is about this is it holy [ __ ] bro why
Billy Idol anyone really care that was
probably there's an iconic video from
the eighties does anyone care I don't
know you Zack you're into this [ __ ] do
you care I mean not really know people
today but filters to go back to that
right why are we forgetting like the
goddamn past happened like do you know
hello
no one wants HD it's like let's go
rewrite history let's go back to the
first photos and make them HD and then
forget that there was ever a photography
buying always like follow ROI cameras
now trying to go back to what it used to
be I hate this the streaming service of
Universal Music Group have teamed up to
revamp more than thousand a thousand
videos from artists including Lady gaga
not that old that's right that's another
they show a frame from that and it's
from a video from nine years ago what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you why the Lady
Gaga old mastered AI fuzz Lady Gaga
[ __ ] huh that was my guess how old
things used to be my voice quality like
when you watch the first episodes of
curb yeah it's pretty shocked it's like
square it doesn't even fit like the
dimensions of the TV Tom Petty video
Billy I don't spice girls you know
they're just trying to revenant some
more revenue some buzz [ __ ] get it
together
Ethan we're trying to generate more
revenue and buzz being like oh you guys
remember these videos that you nobody
watched any more cuz they're 40 years
old it's not gonna work [ __ ] you're
already getting all the revenue you
could ever imagine from claiming
everyone's video and this is the
insanity tusers they're gonna claim this
whole to our podcast because of some
audio some visual content that we're
analyzing in a New York Times article
they're really great business models
they don't even need investors or
anything they're just there's no
recourse there's no motivation for them
really not to from a business standpoint
they should just claim every video on
YouTube I mean and what mr. BAE's views
like he said oh yeah his videos alone
would be you know how much morning and I
talked to him and I'm like you got it
he doesn't even dispute them cuz he's
afraid I don't know why he just doesn't
want to deal with it and I try to talk
to him be like dude you gotta just view
this [ __ ] so mr. beast is bowing at 1520
million views and these guys are just
laughing mm-hmm that's like $50,000 a
pop they're like thank you come again
sorry told my Indian friends those are
boo know I'll poop the problem with the
poo thank you come again
that's um gee so here's what's going on
this is what's happening is that there's
what's been called bounty hunters and it
started happening like this getting
really really bad like [ __ ] like what's
going on with Gus by the way guess who
took down our our last podcast and
blocked a worldwide um gee baby let's go
that's right I'm kind of playing on
their name that we can I know anything
about that Universal you guys submit
your good idea there someone at home is
like I got the perfect one so send us
emails podcast a shoe shoe production
calm your mom gay your mom gay got him
it's pretty good but you so you monkey
yeah my buddy's not fine no monkeys not
good you this is probably not the time
to branch me so you guys sent us you
guys are smarter and funnier than I am
so here's what's going on YouTube has
their autumn a
system that everyone's been using but
YouTube because they're reasonable
doesn't always send things that are
claimable because maybe there's too
small of an amount or maybe they don't
detect it and send it to the copyright
holder because they think that they see
the gray area and so they don't think
that it's claimable they've made that
decision within their own automated
system but what these bounty hunters
have done is that they've developed
their own algorithms that circumvent the
Content ID system and our scanning
content more finely and they approach
big companies like UMG and say hey
YouTube's not doing a good job there's
tons of money out there that you're not
claiming I'm gonna go make you a million
bucks I'm gonna give you half of it you
don't have to worry about anything
you're just gonna get free money for
them to like no brainer but though the
problem is that they have no connection
to what's going on with these bounty
hunters they have no they don't
understand the consequence they don't
understand the methods and they don't
understand that there's no reap they're
toxic it is and these bounty hunters
know exactly what they're doing in fact
I have Intel that they have actual
individuals watching the uploads of all
big youtuber channels so when you see a
manual claim on something like mr. beast
whistling or Gus not you know there's no
way a bot there's certain points where
there's no way a bot would be able to
tell so they have they don't care about
the small chips they care about mr.
beast 20 million views so that have one
individual watching his videos and then
they see it they get a bounty - so it's
all this shake that shaking down so they
automatically they get a fast - right
because they want every penny so the
minute he uploads it you got one of
these [ __ ] maybe even five of them
because they're competing to find that
bounty they send it to the company they
do a manual claim everyone gets paid
except mr. beast that's crazy
yeah so so it's actually not even that
smart because I thought they have their
own like algorithm
it's both it's very I mean it's it's not
that sophisticated but it is also but
it's just it's such a problem
something's got a yeah things got a give
here and I think that companies like um
G need to be educated that making a
couple extra million dollars a year at
the cost of destroying the u2 ecosystem
is not really that valuable
how much is you ng worth 10 trillion
dollars I can only imagine if they're
big as you guys are saying um D value
550 billion okay sounds about right
the [ __ ] out of here 50 billion
[ __ ] like a million dollars from
YouTube matters such [ __ ] yeah it's not
watching your language really is that
because of Theodore Oh what can I say
they're [ __ ] oh we're gonna do no
cursing in front of them
I'm I'm working on that I am at home I'm
good not cursing mm-hmm but here on the
podcast don't able to [ __ ] cut me you
know I shouldn't press your regular uh
my [ __ ] um G sorry you left forgive me
boycott ug we're thinking of making a
video about it we've got a whole damn
thing we're working on me and the guys
we got some testimonials from big
youtubers because we got a boycott um G
we got to hit him where it hurts we
gotta tell the artists we got to tell
the company and one's got to know what's
going on here this is the problem with
me I'm so big though it's hard to
boycott them because it's like yeah you
can't your favorite your favorite artist
like almost guaranteed that's part of
you so don't listen to him anymore yeah
I completely agree with you that's why
we're trying to think of creative ways
to get them to notice yeah I guess like
you said Dave need to be educated
themselves for well yeah the problem
they're creating we just need their
marketing manager to take notice and be
like Oh what is this this is bad PR for
us we need to change this mm-hmm
although the marketing manager is
probably the one with all that extra
revenue looking good
so but someone up high ups got to be
like oh um cheese name is garbage on
YouTube meanwhile everyone keeps buying
the records cuz nobody cares
no we haven't thought we have an idea
but most of all it kind of sucks to see
YouTube of all people who's supposed to
be our ally being like oh um cheese big
ass big [ __ ] feels so good in my ass
shout to um gee they're worth fifty
billion dollars we love T anal beads I
think that works as long as you're
saying YouTube not a specific I'm Susan
I didn't say so yeah you didn't know
she's the CEO if it was a guy I would
say that - I love anal play reach-around
give me a reach-around baby hey
okay whatever we're gonna take a break
guys we have so much more to get to when
we return so don't freaking even think
about going away
you know those times when every day
feels the same like you're on autopilot
how you're so caught up in your routine
that you forget to take care of yourself
well Dulles shave club makes it easy to
take care of yourself when that happens
it's that quality product baby that
makes you feel smell look and your
gosh-darn best I get everything I need
from Dollar Shave Club without going to
the store let's start here with this
meaty weighty beautiful razor that is
probably the only razor on the market it
doesn't give me razor burn I use it on
the back of my neck I have a beard so
you know I use it there is it there you
didn't wanna know where I use it down
there nothing makes a razor glide over
your skin like that shave butter boy you
got to feel this butter on your face to
know what I'm talking about and you'll
save yourself mmm
butter they've got pretty much
everything amazing shave stuff they've
got the razors they've got the body wash
they've got the shampoo they've got the
toothpaste you name it they've got it
it's all happening there their body
washes smells fantastic
you're gonna want to put that in your
butt crack too everything goes in the
buck rack including the me to the the
heavy meaty
razor ends but that's up to you that's
not their recommended use that's just
something I like to get my morning off
right Dollar Shave Club has spent years
developing crafting and refining their
products there's so much better than
anything I've ever used you can get a
Dollar Shave Club starter set boom for
just five bucks it comes with everything
you need to feel great get a great shave
the executive razor the shave butter the
face cleanser you're gonna love it as
much as I do and I do love it get your
starter set for just $5 at
dollarshaveclub.com
slash h3 that's dollarshaveclub.com
slash h3
listening makes us smarter and more
connected people there's no better place
to listen audible members choose three
titles every month one audiobook plus
two audible originals that you can't
hear anywhere else you just go to a you
d ible dot-com slash h3 podcast or text
h3 podcast 2 500 500 and browse their
unmatched selection of audio content
most of here's what I want to tell you
about I've been listening to the Witcher
a game that I and many of us gamer boys
out there love and I don't know that
everyone knows but that whole Witcher
universe was built off these novels that
existed before I think there's something
like 10 novels that bill and expanded
this big beautiful world so I highly
recommend with a new there's a Witcher
TV series coming out on Netflix which is
super exciting and I highly recommend
you guys get into it now get in on those
details man The Witcher novels are on
audible and I definitely check them out
start listening with a 30-day trial and
your first audiobook plus two audible
originals are free when you go to
audible.com slash HTTP podcast or text
h3 p OD c AST to 500 500 get witcher for
free freaking listen audible gay okay
it's dinnertime you're fat you're
starving your stomach hurts you don't
know what to do to go to eat sound
familiar
yeah everyday every night of my life
guess what with door - you don't need to
get up from the couch and you don't need
to cook a meal and you definitely don't
need to clean it up anymore either
door - connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city them ordering
is easy just use the door - app and
choose what you want to eat and a Dasher
will bring it to you any where you are
not only is that burger place you love
on door - already but over three hundred
and ten thousand other amazing
restaurants are to door - connects you
with door to door delivery in over 3300
cities in all 50 states and canada
well canada i'm surprised anyone goes up
their order from your local go to Zoar
choose from your favorite chains like
Chipotle wendy's chick-fil-a and the
cheese factory don't worry about dinner
guys let's dinner come to you take a day
off for Christ's sake you deserve it
with door - here's the special offer
there's gonna blow your freakin mind
right now our listeners get five dollars
off their first order of $15 or more
when you download door - app and enter
promo code HD did I hear a free five
dollars on your dinner order sorry say
that again that's five dollars off your
first order when you download the door -
app from the App Store and enter promo
code h3 again that's promo code HD for
five dollars off your first order from
door -
nobody's got time to go to the post
office you're busy we're all busy so
who's going through traffic parking
lugging you gotta lugged your packages
it's a freaking hassle give me a break
the year is 2019 let's start acting like
it with stamps calm they bring all the
amazing services of the u.s. post office
right to your computer whether your
small office sending invoices and online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
you just hand it off to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it's
that simple
well Sam comm you get five cents off
every first class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail so it's even cheaper
give me a break it's a no-brainer stamps
calm saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm right
now our listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in h3
that stamps calm look for that micro
microphone and enter h3
glad to have you back EULA thank you
it's nice to be max nice to have my
wingmom chin I winged Hmong speaking of
boycotts something disgusted me almost
as much as this UMG business possibly
even more our boy Jack Jack's film
friend of the show upstanding citizen
and as everybody knows has the record
for the deepest dab fortnight ripped off
his [ __ ] deep dab didn't credit him
didn't ask him for permission didn't
even be like hey I'm a I'm a they're
making money potentially millions of
dollars off this deep dad watch this
[ __ ] we about to purchase my own this is
not okay we need to rally the troops the
h3h3 army is say the guy from the fresh
Carlton yeah yeah except the difference
is that I feel like I feel like there's
a difference one being that that's a
whole - he's an individual who he
developed this deep dab he had a whole
video about the deepest dad possible
okay and and number three knows the
biggest reason is this is my friend all
right it's not cool I tweeted out what's
the CC you about that seriously of what
do you think they only mine anything for
tonight
yeah well they're [ __ ] yes they owe
him yeah they should pay up man well
watch this video and you tell me
afterwards but the h3h3 army i'm your
general freebish maximus and we are
going to war finally we found something
to go to war with CEO of fortnight
what's the Epic Games right yeah what
our accounts Tim Sweeney look at this
nerd sorry I shouldn't say that but pay
up babe who else
tweet all these all these epic game guys
how much are they worth
Oh fifteen billion yeah you can afford
to pay him a couple hundred thousand
which is what you owe him maybe even
anything so let me see yeah okay I just
want we need a call to action but here
literally about to purchase my own emote
and fort
I call the deep dab that's what Jack
called it that's me I'm Siri can we play
that again that's me man there socially
yeah that's my deep dad oh no I need to
get some v bucks first let me do that
let's get some v bucks all right how
much is to be buck do we now use my code
real Jax Phil do but does anyone play
for at night how much is 200 v bucks the
code of it for tonight has this thing
where you can make a code so that when
you buy it it's helped support that
person a little bit it's nothing Jack
set it up himself he told me right
before he told me like this morning that
he's made $300 from it what she
shouldn't be he shouldn't even be they
probably made you know $30,000 from his
code but what the millions of people are
playing this didn't even know that it
where it came from and the deep dab is
such an epic original concept that he
personally invented anything that they
they own like a license whew
what would you okay truthfully it's
probably legally gray mm-hmm okay yeah
so there's good practices and there's
bad practices is it legally uh is it
legal what they did probably because the
Carlton thing got thrown out as far as
I'm aware although Jack may have thrown
out exactly that's actually still
pending
okay well probably because it's hard to
prove that Jack has ownership over this
well no the problem is that you can't
patent a dance move or something like
that something some kind of weird thing
but I think that even jacksFilms has a
better claim to owning this then Carlton
does yeah by far because Jack made a
whole video about it and hold develop
video about developing the concept they
used the exact same name it's like it's
like a comedy bit by a comedian anyway
exactly so I think if Jack wanted to sue
them which I'm sure he doesn't if you
wanted to go up against a 20 billion or
like a you know 20 billion dollar
company as an individual he's not
probably gonna get very far
that's why I'm saying there's good
practices and there's bad practices what
they're doing here is a very bad bad
practice very bad bad faith anti creator
anti individual practice this is the
bigeye versus the little guy if they
were good they were good practices what
you do see in companies sometimes for
example great practice was with was the
name overkill in a payday - such a great
practice they did with us where they
were very open handed we were together
they wanted to put us in the game now if
they wanted to put this dab in the game
they should have been in touch with Jack
from the beginning they should have said
hey we're gonna pay you and they should
even have collaborated and been like you
know what let's do a collaboration where
you announce and he would have loved it
yes talked about it it would have been a
whole something for everybody but they
they essentially stole and I do I think
frankly he does have a good legal case
you know I think he does they stole his
joke right which well watch this I mean
it's like the same thing in common the
word like it's not illegal but it's
really bad no one's gonna respect you
that's right except it's even worse
because you guys were twenty billion
dollars and and they're selling it it's
not like you go buy I mean joke is one
thing but it's like buy this deep stab
and also I don't know if they called the
Carlton the Carlton I doubt it because
that would prove they stole from him but
Jack called it the deep dad rushes
let's buy my own emote what is that like
two bucks yeah I looked it up a hundred
bucks is a dollar okay so here's what
happened yesterday a ton of you guys
sent me screen caps and videos and gifts
of a supposed leak in the next fortnight
update or something and all of these
leaks included this deep dab as an emote
and thank you guys so much for sending
this to me
for tonight epic games did not contact
me about this I had no prior knowledge
that this emote was going into the game
and by the way can we just compare the
two movies because it
yeah same thing you can't be like oh
yeah that kind of looks like it no no
they it's practically mocast life you
would have thought I want you to do put
on a mote cap it's the same thing they
did the Carleton when you watch them
side-by-side you're like no they just
captured that yeah also he's the only
man a capable of doing a deep dab that
deep he's trained professional
he's like the yogi master this punch a
piece of wood in the same place like a
million times and therefore his fists as
hard as rock and he's the only one that
could punch it with an inch away from it
following of my terrible video from
exactly two years ago to the Milo if we
need this of course jack is always ahead
of his time he's like such as thought it
was a new video
dude Jack is that always comes out with
these gems where it's like the deepest
dad my deepest dad
two years later fortnight's picking it
up get real dude I want Jack to I need
Jack to be paid $100,000 for this and
and recognized that's what I want the
h3h3 army I your general foolish Maximus
command you we must get justice for
Jack's films for this deep dab and then
it hit me
I can make a creator code because the
fortnight is gonna put this move behind
a paywall I may as well benefit from it
a little bit so as of yesterday I do set
up the code which I which well he's just
going and making them more money you
know what I mean he said he made 300
bucks from it they probably give him
like 1% yeah we demand justice does
episode is about still Ian it's not okay
Tim so here we go
Tim Sweeney epic games on Twitter you
know I saw this guy's Twitter account
he's the head of a [ __ ] video game
company this guy should be from well
familiar with tech look at his profile
picture and ask what the [ __ ]
140 tim pixel and pixel by the way
every 10,000 VBox spent towards that
purchase Jack gets five bucks so it's
basically five percent gross yeah so the
fact that he made three hundred means
that do the math for me real quick
Oh three hundred yeah I mean crushes
numbers - no I mean it means that they
sold like tens of thousands right yeah
and that's just the people that use his
which is probably comparatively almost
nothing right if at the very least they
should just Auto apply his code to
anybody buying that you know what I mean
like at least give him the right person
universe yeah only 5% for people that
know his yes do they have epic games
customer service Twitter I want to give
people I mean we need a call-to-action
here because clearly teams team pixel
Todd or whatever his name is isn't gonna
hear it let's hit up in Epic Games and
say we demand justice for Jack Bupa army
is here we are here we are legion we do
not forget or forgive jacksFilms owns
the deep dab and we maybe should I let
them word it we demand action for Jack's
film they can word their own to its
angry we he does he demands to be
compensated for this epic games also
that move is probably a real hit yes
well it's 6,000 is how much was soul the
epic made for him to make 300 but again
I'm sure they sold way more than bro
they're gonna statues of thousands of
dollars not yeah so do you think this
one did he tweet last oh he retweeted
something seven hours ago so head up to
Tim Sweeney and also mentioned chanted
to update us a profile pic to eat owns a
tech company for Christ's sake maybe it
thinks it's an epic maybe thinks it's
funny irony gag I guess
well either way tweet his ass let's see
what he's been up to he's talking [ __ ]
about him valve Shh
give me a break yeah let's get justice
for our boy Jack this is unacceptable oh
that's me my gut all right okay let's
move on
panicking slightly dead air I closed my
document you entertained them the next
thing up in your dock is okay if you
want to give a little intro to this no
I'm just gonna Oh Jay Sampson is a man
with a knife who killed two people was
it in the 90s uh yeah mid 90s mid 90s
for a younger audience I mean everybody
knows Oh Jay but Oh Jay was a phenomenal
he was a superstar basket player
basketball player no he wasn't football
I meant thank you
football and he had started dabbling in
movies as well he's become quite a
famous actor he was pretty much one of
the most famous he was kinda like LeBron
James of the time if I'm being honest he
was like a household name is in the
Naked Gun Naked Gun exactly and he was a
very likeable guy to it I mean everyone
loves seeing him on screen he was a
great football player he had it all
going on except until one day his wife
and lover were found murdered viciously
yada yada yada he went on trial ex wife
by the way XY they were divorced okay
thank you he there was this trial that
was like televised it was like the
biggest fricking they were calling it
the trial of the century really and it
was in fact there's a great documentary
about it we watched on H on Netflix
people the people were so J Simpson or
something yeah that's what it's going
I'm so good if you don't have followed
that whole saga it's definitely watched
I'm really good so he was also
investigated for domestic violence while
he was married to
Nicole Brown who was his murdered
ex-wife they got a divorce
yada yada yada there was all this crazy
things but anyway they found a glove and
the murder weapon
they found his eye his I don't even know
how the [ __ ] he got off but everyone now
justice is like common knowledge friends
I think it became a race issue it was a
race yeah I mean that was part of it and
the other big part of it was the police
were crooked his [ __ ] well and most of
their evident they're they're proof
hinged on DNA evidence and that was a
very new concept at the time and most
people think that the jurors can just
understand how legit the fact that his
DNA was all over the crime scene that
that they didn't realize that how
significant that was interesting yeah
and there was one pivotal moment that's
kind of historic is like in the
documentary they show what a big deal
was but apparently in case law you never
want to give the defendant control of
key evidence so they gave AJ the glove
that was found to be the the love that
where they were murdered him but he wore
a glove and he twisted his thumb around
and [ __ ] to make it look like the glove
didn't fit and so there's this famous
line if the if it don't fit you must
acquit I thought he was wearing like a
plastic glove he was evidence yeah I
didn't want to contaminate it yeah but
also he was like you know not it's easy
it's easy to like jet your thumb out and
be like it doesn't go on you know it's
also just like what is the glove being
slightly small have to do exactly but
again that's why that's why the attorney
was like don't give the central piece of
evidence to the defendant because they
can do dumb [ __ ] like that and then all
the sudden there's doubt in people's
mind anyway this guy's such a such a
winner he was acquitted of murder and he
was uh but he was found he was found to
be at fault in civil case so the family
of the murdered pseudo J Simpson for
wrongful death and actually won it was
an out of trip yeah so he's been paying
that their family off for many years
and then in Vegas him being the winner
and fantastic dude that he is he
committed Rob he armed robbery stealing
back his own memorabilia from a Vegas
casino and he served nine years in
prison for that can you imagine getting
off on murder and then going to prison
for some dumbass [ __ ] like that stealing
your now it wasn't the chase so there
was this famous chase that was during
the trial where he's like I'm going to
Mexico he was in this white Bronco he
had a gun to his head he's like I'm
going to Mexico I'm gonna kill myself
whatever he's [ __ ] crazy so anyway the
whole point of all this recap is that he
is on Twitter he opened a Twitter
account and everybody's been climbing on
him it's been so good I have so much
sure there's one of my favorite stories
of the year it's so much fun now first
of all the great first fact is that he
opened his Twitter account on the 25th
anniversary of the murder is that a
coincidence or is that okay it's a well
another thing about OJ's that he wrote a
book called if I did it and it was so
grotesque that nobody would publish it
really yeah I guess someone was going to
publish it and everyone's like dude
that's [ __ ] up and then they dropped
him and he wrote it was a it was a
hypothetical account of if he did it
yeah you believe that psycho yeah he's a
psycho so let's go here and see the OJ
Simpson the real OJ 32 baby what's the
32 I think there's just a lot of parity
accounts no that was his number at the
top come on
so about 30 minutes this is this gets so
good you guys so after about 30 minutes
of making his account somebody hacked it
and starts tweeting [ __ ] this is the
real oj 32 where the [ __ ] at I killed
her I didn't kill anybody
let's link our Kelly there's one where
there's a racial slur here that I don't
want to show but some they say the
n-word yeah and yeah so I and then it
shows here account suspected
huh but he recovered his account hey can
even love that it took like [ __ ] 20
minutes I somebody to get into that [ __ ]
and be tweeting I killed her
can you imagine because he made a video
when he first made it to prove it was
him
where's that video I think you just
scroll down it's actually it's still up
here the person this is yours truly
hello to the world this is yours truly
wait what is this one Weiser's no no I
all the way that's the truly coming soon
the Twitter you'll get to read all my
thoughts and opinions on just about
everything now there's a lot of fake oj
accounts out there so this one at the
real oj 32 is the only official one so
it should be a lot of fun I got a little
getting even to do so god bless take
care sorry
okay let's not have do you know what
happens when AJ gets even yeah why did
he what is he getting even about also
why is what's with this people it's got
the same vibe as Garth Facebook video I
like was like I'm just cooking down the
walls between you and me really like
that I love watching all those videos
what else we got here but I when he said
I got getting even to do I was like
[ __ ] this guy's threatening my
life Twitter there's no accountability
sports fantasy football and even
politics but for now let me just say to
my fellow fathers out there happy
Father's Day happy Father's Day to Ron
and Nicole his parents father yes you
know what yes yes good that's right
every every video he made as it as a
little touch of like of a threat yeah
I'm getting even like you got score
to settle all this time you guys thought
you could say whatever you want about me
he's definitely murdered them not
anymore
so here let's see if there's any threats
in the third one oh it's truly you know
this is my first venture into the social
media world and it's amazing you know
especially how quickly they could put up
counterfeit sites anyway we'll deal with
that what Bo Dallas exactly I'll do the
sports world
this is his published base okay be cool
we'll be talking about the once in a
while I'm a long time Papa can talk
about something else and this is one of
those times you know he's like a brother
to me he's a great guy he met married
Chris and they really had a terrific
time together when they were together
unfortunately I killed them oh but never
never in any way shape or form have I
ever had any interest in Chris
romantically there's a long-running
rumor that she is what is it Khloe Khloe
Kardashian's real father
oh don't know if there's any well it
even that he's denying it obviously What
did he say he said we'll take care of
that later
tasteless that's Ken you on Mauryan
pyramid like all the girls I'm very
proud of just like I knew Bob would be
if he was here but the simple fact of
the matter is she's not mine now to say
is my manager I have one manager in my
whole life Chuck Barnes when I came out
of USC for three years unfortunately he
died about 45 years ago but with the
help of skipped half my lawyer my two
assistants Marilyn O'Brien the late
Marilyn O'Brien a why is everyone dead
my two assistants the late Marian
O'Brien damn Oh J
and I've always managed my own I like
the thing very successful so when you
see these guys like norm and these guys
claim that they're my manager is just
not true and they have done a deal here
they're one of these guys and and I'll
make sure they never see the Sun again
that's it for today take care bro for
happy Father's Day sending out threats
of the world yeah so anyway this would
AJ's been up to it but now so this [ __ ]
oh my god this part is insane so there's
a parody account of OJ Simpson there's
been so many of them cuz he's not been
on Twitter of OJ with a knife and he
makes all these jokes about how OJ
killed mm-hmm
the two Nicole and what was her
boyfriend's name Nicole and Ron go Ron
Goldman and he starts threatening him in
the DM z-- bro like og doesn't realize
that because he's so new he doesn't
understand that Dan's aren't actually
private and just just take the man you
wouldn't never guess who the hell this
messaged me on Twitter in Adina [ __ ] Oh
Jay Simpson just messaged me I loo this
is complaining and everything right
delete this account I will have my boy
remove it for false misleading content I
didn't post so I'm like all right cool
you know I don't think he knows that
you're allowed to have a parody account
with Twitter or not but I do this I said
uh and if I don't you gonna stab me -
yeah lying you me and millions know the
truth
you tripping over a parody account lol
welcome to Twitter bro this guy and he
said like I said delete this parody
account bro imagine you made a
odj parody account - slam dunk on him
and then OJ's DMing you all butthurt
that's the dream for one of these
internet trolls but luck and he only has
like 300 for
right a small thing I guess yes dude
watch this [ __ ] around and he said like
I said delete this parody account as you
call it or face serious consequences by
me I'll find your ass one way or another
so don't mess with me I got nothing to
lose grow up okay so I sent his ass okay
we're gonna thumbs up right look what is
that symbol like it dude that's crazy
and I go what you gonna kill me too this
is the [ __ ] you got your ass locked up
the second time it should have been the
first get it together and take her pills
brah brah it's a pity
dunking and this for you guys gonna say
his thing and now he's on no that's that
yeah oh just too much
the real oj 32 he's proving it
this is this Shipra so there's that
there's a update video as well this
crazy [ __ ] dude they continue the
conversation continues again so Oh Jay
Dion's me again okay we'll check this
out
it's his actual account I'm gonna click
it here in a minute and show you guys he
continues with the odium he goes think
I'm playing [ __ ] and I go Sally
nope
look if you're look look if my little
Twitter account with 300 followers bugs
use that much then manny weakest [ __ ]
okay so I only get 300 one follows I
seen you seen that video you just posted
about me think I'm playing tired of all
your [ __ ]
Apple I will find your Isaac like you
don't believe me just watch and see
[ __ ] what is it literally have more
followers than me and more convincing
than mine left myself you gonna [ __ ]
rage with all knife emojis next I mean
come on this literally is the OJ it's
really wild I wonder if this is like
okay I go to get him in legal trouble
when I waive single me out that's all
good I don't mind having a parody
account
this actually is funny to me he goes
just wait I'm gonna bless your ass all
over Twitter 400 J should not be sending
knife emojis the students
like if you if you're OJ Simpson's right
oh he's still typing oh my god right now
Oh Jay Simpson if there's one emoji you
should not be using it's a knife emoji
yeah look crazy I thought I'd be getting
even I got a little getting even to do
what a [ __ ] psycho
yeah wonderfully I can get his ass back
in prison for sending knife emojis
because when it comes from a known
murderer that comes for a little more
than just goofing around I'm just I
wonder if he has anyone around him like
is no one advising him he's too
old-school he's on this phone on Twitter
nobody knows what - Oh Jason honest on
Twitter here these are some new parody
accounts now that are popping up Oh real
Oh Jay 32 can't believe these mother
effers got my name wrong and he's got
the black Club
RJ with the black love and blood on the
Starbucks mm-hmm beautiful that one's
not gonna make him happy he blocked the
Dolan dark apparently so congratulations
to Dolan dark Dolan dark said could I
get your opinion on how you got away
with murdering your wife you've been
blocked Oh Jay you're not ready for
Twitter bro no brah brah yeah you can't
just walk away from technology and come
back on Twitter especially as Oh Jay
okay and just to put a little perfect
bow on top of this here somebody linked
this old interview look yeah enjoy this
got me started did you do it no I did
nope he had a surprise for me and I
genuinely was surprised I think it was
his idea of a joke and this is it watch
this okay you really missed it did not
do it after we finished filming O'Jays
said to me that he had a surprise for me
and I genuinely was surprised I think it
was his idea of a joke and this is it oh
my god
and it was so free boo who are listening
the audio she opened the door and he had
a knife in his hand and was doing like
the sago like I was a banana was a
banana yeah and then he did these huge
crazy eyes at the camera afterwards
crazy Wow yeah Oh Jay something else man
but like I mean I think Oh Jay
threatening a parody account with knives
will go down it's one of my favourite
things we've ever walked out on the show
it's so good oh speaking of um speaking
of people who shouldn't be on Twitter
back on Twitter Bill Cosby America's dad
is on Twitter to wish everybody a Happy
Father's Day now first before I read it
to you let's enjoy his banner his panner
is just I'm not really sure what's going
on here on the left side and then and
then when you click is logo it's Bill
Cosby far from finished order now on
Amazon is that really available on
Amazon the yellow and the pudding you
put the pudding didn't to get low
I'm so bad at impressions but and then
so this is like real old people Facebook
[ __ ] so then he makes a happy dad tweet
and he tweets the same exact thing three
times now it's not him right cuz he's in
prison
I don't know I saw someone say that it's
his wife Rhynie yeah it's gotta be
somebody well I was like good for you
bill you can use Twitter in prison I
didn't know that hey hey hey it's
America's dad I know it's late but to
all the dads it's an honor to be
fathers so let's make today a RINO dothe
to fulfill our purpose strengthen our
families and not to drugged women and
roofie them know and then he tweets the
same thing three times literally the
same exact message hey hey it's
America's dad I know it's late but then
he added a hashtag happy Father's Day
with a little video at rest oh the video
actually has no real relevance at all I
have to sleep breaking up the black it's
about breaking up black family I'm all
for history to teach it's got my rock
history right straight happy Treader and
three times a charm
hey hey it's Father's Day yep
yes also I think they keep using this
like hash tag free Bill Cosby Oh for
real in the tweets so they maintain his
innocence to this day but it's all set
up
let's see June teens continue to raise
hell Central Park five free Bill Cosby
they're like whoa let's not mix those
[Laughter]
that's so fine March for freedom gay
rights women's choice free Bill Cosby
it's like whoa let's not lump those all
together hmm you know I mean I love it
love it love it love it love it
what do you think about this I saw this
and it kind of shocked me Kim K I'm
fascinated with Kim K I can't stop
talking about her this is her mom's hand
she invented this thing body or grandma
body makeup let me show you this
cuz it is
well the best product she probably
didn't invent it but it is it work it
doesn't work remarkably well but yeah
they probably do this like on coroner's
probably been using this [ __ ] for
hundreds of years
yeah well the people who like take care
of dead bodies for a job they make them
look nice and stuff she's like I just
took this straight from the corners you
can look good while you're still alive
so she that's kind of explain where her
makeup guy puts it on her mm-hmm and
she's like he always had this like small
supply of this product that we could
never find anywhere so we made it
ourselves some wonder if they didn't get
it somewhere like takers yeah well
what's the big deal anyway it's just
like a beige arm color it's like
foundation right yeah yeah but anyway I
mean the idea of walking wrong with
makeup will let me play the video
walking around makeup on your obviously
it's amazing you make a beautiful dancer
that's amazing how long does that stay
on it rubs right off
I mean for me it stays on really all day
she puts it on you're not touching
anything if you walk around like this
and it does it I mean it does work
really hard it's pretty incredible but
you don't work and now grandma you're
ready to for the open casket funeral
imagine you're going to that's the dark
I'm sorry but it's true that's what this
is what coroner's do you're going to
someone's house and they're like a white
couch and they're like have a seat and
rights right you can't tell because
obviously if you saw a girl who's
wearing
put her face hmm come up all [ __ ] up
but now Nana who's so old she forgot
she's got makeup on her arms sits down
so why is every time Nana's over here
our couch gets all smudged up with brown
here Nana put the we've got your makeup
on no here's the casket if you want to
just rest here it's like rehearsal okay
Wow like is that for women for a moment
yeah they already got to worry about so
much now we're gonna worry about this eh
I'm gonna put makeup on our body on your
freaking hand can we have come on you
know what I'm saying yes we're kidding I
mean on one hand Kim Kardashian just
wants to sell more product she's like oh
well [ __ ] arms let's cover the arms
but it's like think of the people man
Kim Kardashian's walk around with an arm
makeup well I think if you set it a
little bit of mostly powder
yeah but cheap look how fat she lightly
dabs there yeah that happened on my
couch I would not be happy look how it
doesn't come on I think that's a great
point heel it's like can we just let the
ladies have a break we got to worry
about our hair read this and that
eyebrows hair
it's atlas now we got to put a makeup on
our buddy anal bleaching never ends I
mean seriously think about anal
bleaching like how like that's the
ultimate you got to worry about how your
anus looks okay like - give me a break
over here huh yeah that's a really good
point but these makeup girls they're
just they're unreasonably rich and it
kind of pissing me off lately cuz I was
talking about last episode I'm not
becoming a billionaire selling clothing
you know what's [ __ ] up about the
makeup they get you hooked it's like a
drug they up charge your ass it costs
like 20 cents to make they charge you 50
bucks so already they're margin insane
but it's a consumable product on my
clothing that can last for
ever if you buy a good product so they
consume it and then they get addicted to
where it's like oh I can't go outside
unless I have my makeup I don't feel
confident I don't feel like myself and I
like this once when I'm gonna buy buy
buy buy buy and you have these girls
spending five hundred thousand dollars a
month on makeup I got this comment a lot
like my mom was just here telling me
like yesterday you're so lucky that you
don't need makeup but I don't know how I
feel about that statement I don't know
if I'm being like unfair but I don't
think anyone needs me no I think you're
you've never wore makeup and therefore
people are used to seeing you without me
yeah it mean sometimes I look like I
just woke up even though I didn't
because I'm not wearing wake up and I
can look pale or whatever but but that's
just how I look I don't know I'm not
gonna worry about it I think most women
it's just a matter of how you're used to
seeing yourself that applies to guys too
and so you you draw your confidence in
your normal miss bite when you look in
the mirror and you see okay that's what
I'm used to seeing so so if girls never
wore makeup to begin with and that's how
they were used to seeing themselves they
wouldn't be addicted to it
mm-hm and I think that's where you like
like I've had that experience when I'll
just shave all the sudden and I look
totally normal there one else but I'm
like oh my god I can't go outside yeah I
am so embarrassed I am so I'm so ugly
I'm disgusting I'm not going I'm not
leaving the house I remember one time in
college I shaved I thought I look so bad
I wouldn't even go downstairs and I and
I bet girls feel the same way about
makeup because they're used to seeing
themselves like that obviously if your
face is shaved every guy walks around
the shave face nobody's gonna look at
you any different yeah it's just a
matter of they get you addicted there
they make you feel like you need it and
then once you start using it you can't
see yourself without it and now this
[ __ ] selling you arm makeup nipple
makeup container bleach lip gloss but
seriously but seriously you got the
lipstick you've got the gloss you got
the eyeliner you got the paint it's like
how many [ __ ] makeups you would do we
need I mean seriously how much do girls
spend on makeup every month I don't
I find ribs hundreds I've never been
down in the mix I personally don't feel
like my I feel like I'm dirty when I
have makeup on like I feel like it can't
touch my face yeah cuz something's gonna
come off I won't want to walk around
like Vaseline on my face just seems so
gross but you gave back so but the but
it's expensive
yes it's very expensive and just think
about all these rich all these like
Beauty people who are popping up and you
keep hearing about how rich they are
it's like yeah
Geoffrey star Kylie Jenner it's like
even [ __ ] Tati or whatever all this
stupid low-level [ __ ] they're making
millions of dollars because it's just
such a [ __ ] I don't wanna say con but
it's like a sleazy business it's like a
drug dealer you got crazy margins you
got people addicted you got people that
they need more they're always needing
more that's what I'm saying I'm in the
wrong business I could start selling
Super Trouper our makeup because I'm not
ever gonna become a billionaire so I'm
sure people are into makeup or probably
will probably completely disagree what
we saying right now cuz we're like I
don't think so
I think I'm betting on the whole I think
they know in their makeup is an art form
like really yes not everyday though yeah
and a lot of girls staple it up slop it
on they slop it on you know when you
were uh when you were growing up did you
uh use makeup like in high school
never never did you have I don't know at
all when you were kid I think that's
what a lot of girls start with it is
there like ashamed of having a bunch of
pimples I was ashamed of my pimples for
sure but you just rocked it but you know
I think you just didn't like I think Eva
has a tactile issue like sunscreen you
just don't like stuff on your face right
so you never went through the process
wearing the makeup and now you came out
of it and everyone's like oh you're so
lucky you don't need makeup it's like no
you're all just used to me not wearing
makeup
mm-hmm women are they're all beautiful
they all beautiful without makeup
it's just what you're used to seeing I
don't understand these before-and-afters
whenever I see like makeup before and
after
most of the times I don't show an
article about girls during labor they'll
bring their makeup said for the pictures
and do like complete crazy makeup eyes
then you take a picture that's like
gonna be your big picture with the baby
that's mental illness do you understand
how insane that is during labor that is
so insane and I totally believe it you
know so I can't think
I think makeups a racket why is Kylie
Jenner a billionaire why is Jeffrey star
like a [ __ ] trillionaire who [ __ ]
cares dude you know I'm pissed that I'm
not making that much money we need to
make closer like evaporate how do we
make clothes that you can eat and they
evaporate on your potty yeah I'm making
enough money with this [ __ ] clothing
[ __ ] um okay there's two more videos I
want to watch Judge Judy kicks out a
dude for having too much fun
you can watch Judge Judy she breaks this
poor guy's heart he's having such a fun
time apparently he was laughing too loud
and she didn't like it but just watch
this the gaze of Judy's life out it's
like a Tim and Eric yeah what did he do
he looks mortified you laugh too hard he
enjoyed himself too much and then the
ponytail yeah he has a ponytail that's
why but everyone was laughing you got
too hard I'm sure in the studio is
probably coming off louder than what we
could hear I guess she thought he was
doing some kind of shenanigans maybe to
be heard or something in the episode
but he looks absolutely mortified I love
the day off to come watch this show
you're my favorite
I will having it imagine like you travel
to LA you love Judge Judy you finally
there you're loving every second you're
laughing you're enjoying yourself and
judge Judy's like you get the [ __ ] out
and then the cult of Judy it's almost
like everyone else there's about to
start spitting on him two on the way out
[ __ ] you you're not one of us [ __ ]
amazing you know what's the best - they
didn't cut this out she loves it she
didn't cut it out she character this guy
didn't sign up to be publicly shamed
he's just come to enjoy the show
yet she's kept in this part where she's
publicly shaming this pedestrian and
showing his face close-ups of his face
get out poor guy what did he do it's
whenever you laugh towards some ways do
you think it's a good life no it's not
what it is mr. Coffey it's what you make
it I just thought we got a little life
lesson at the end there tonight
remember mr. Cuffy that little Danny
yeah you did yeah how was it thank you
so congratulations - oh my god I'm not
in it thank you
I can't watch it when I'm in it I know I
don't like I watched it with you part of
it and I okay oh yeah I push the button
to pause it and it's a little delayed
and then goes back and I pause it yeah
okay that's beside the point
I don't like watching it and I'll tell
you why because when I come in here and
form I want to do it in a vacuum I don't
want to do it about like Oh what I think
about that or I don't want to be
self-aware at all really as little as
possible so when I watch means there are
certain points I think especially in the
beginning were we were having audio
issues or I have a tendency to talk over
the gas or I have bad habits on the mic
where I'll be like mmm something I'm
still working on but I think for the
most part at least now I like to just be
here in a vacuum as much as possible I
don't agree yeah yeah I don't want my
own doubts in my head and I don't want
the audience's voices in my head either
because that's some point it was getting
hard to express yourself without even
before saying anything you already start
thinking what are they gonna think about
what I'm gonna say right and it's like
paralyzing you end up not saying
anything you lose your authenticity in a
way which is the reason we have to
assume why people are watching it begin
with is that we're here hanging out and
I'm expressing myself authentically so I
think as a performer you don't want to
watch too much of yourself that's at
least for me like I think you especially
something like this podcast I mean it's
pretty cringy watching yourself and
you're like oh I sound like that I said
that you know like why am i itching yeah
right now like I'm plucking a [ __ ]
that's probably good day and I was like
trying to get a eyebrow hair off for
doing that this is so let's wrap it up
here with a trump man and again I'm not
getting political on your asses we can
all appreciate this left and right ela
you probably haven't seen this tell me
what you think now at some point I might
but at some point up they get it because
it's a finale it's a fantastic financial
statement it's a fantastic financial
salmon and let's do that over he's
coughing in the middle of my aunt's yeah
okay I don't like that you know like
he's clowning is keeping staff in front
of the cameras like I was like I don't
like
you know and like no I don't know but
there he goes you should go outside but
they're inside a closed room like
there's really an a coffee is very
spontaneous yeah I'm not sure how you
can criticize someone for that but I
wonder if he was trying to tell him to
be like oof
don't go there 100 percenter prett it
yeah I might but at some point I'll talk
about just a bit it's a fantastic
financial statement and Trump's
prophecies he's coughing in the middle
of my aunt's yeah okay and so he covers
it up by being like tries to be super
offended by the cough but I think he was
like bro don't go there
on the financial statements because
that's that was kind of you could cough
way more quiet than that the guy was
like I agree that I think he was trying
to interrupt him but I don't know I
thought if it kind of seems like Trump
didn't pick up on it but I think
overcompensating to make it look like he
was actually upset and that he did [ __ ]
for your internal chest which was very
slick yeah I think he was a slug to me
forties chest baby you're not on the
international level of I thought there
was only a cough going on here and then
guy look despite what a lot of liberals
say I do think Trump is a very
intelligent strategic guy so usually
like like if you're in his position how
do you react if your chief of staff is
being like shut up they'll talk about
that how can you how can you transition
out of that and not make it look
painfully obvious that you're you don't
want to talk about that and that your
chief of staff is tipping you off not to
mention it and this is kind of the best
way possible
what about the rest of the clip though
does he actually stop talking about it
after let's watch I think he doesn't
you'll save it and you can see it's
Teddy's properties look us coffee after
his coffee starts thinking and sorry
yeah I know I just want to catch the
cops
Karin Schill statement it's a fantastic
financial saving oh my god I think at
the cuff I'm sorry I apologize to
everybody I'm just going back to uni but
at some point they get it because it's a
fantastic financial statement it's a
fantastic financial salmon and let's do
that over he's coughing in the middle of
my aunt's yeah okay I don't like that
you know your chief of staff you got a
coffee please
just get just to change the shine sorry
okay you want to do that a little
differently then yeah so at some point
so at some point I look forward to so he
was going back in but what did he say he
said come on I look forward to frankly
I'd like to have people see him I guess
it is the same so maybe it was just
butter we give Trump too much credit
okay see I think you're right about the
chief of staff trying to give him a
heads up I just think he didn't pick up
on it but then why would he be so
offended that he like imagine the chief
of staff is like trying to tip him off
and then Trump doesn't get it and it's
just about her steady coffee Trump was a
[ __ ] TV star for ten years and on a
Hollywood set if you cough yeah you get
kicked out I mean that's a name you know
so I guess we'll never know and of
falling back on his media training kind
of thing just like his tax returns we'll
never know yeah there you go
great either way great fun either way
shall we get well let's get one more
update of baby Theodore as we sign out
here today what is he doing right now we
welcome back ela Klein from the mom army
I urge everybody to call to action today
want tweet at pixel Todd from Epic Games
find out the sea of epic games and tell
him that we demand justice for Jack
mm-hmm and also make sure to go to TAFE
fresh calm because we have totally lost
our minds few percent off 50% off crazy
teddy fresh sail
daddy fresh calm 50% off that [ __ ]
it's good though it's not you're driving
with me thank you
chairs anyway it's good to have you back
um thank you
and by the way yes I want to say you did
a great job I did do a the last two
episodes oh thank you
I watched them at home and I really
enjoyed it well thank you look at you
lover you're being all sweet and nice to
me
yep what I do it appreciate yeah what I
did deserve the sign that's it just
sweet about it so much just can you play
attack Jill what's up yeah alright guys
well stuff army we'll see you next week
- love you appreciate you wish you all
the best and it's 13 minutes long so Dan
to cut us off
[Music]